let's just take you to the latest images
that we are getting from the sky news
helicopter this is over thornton heath
on the outskirts of london and this is
the explosion uh that we saw
at a house over the weekend it happened
yesterday an explosion and a fire and
you can really see uh the extent of what
happened from that explosion there uh
it's in croydon in in south east london
uh on galpin's road the cause of the
fire and the explosion is not yet known
or understood there were six
firefighters and 40
fire engines sorry six fire engines 45
fighters on the scene and the entire
house has now collapsed it happened just
after seven o'clock this morning
crews from norbury mitchum west norwood
and woodside were all sent there but
wow the whole house has
exploded as you can see
and the houses on both sides affected
you can see a an emergency service
worker just walking over the rubble
there but the entire house reduced to
less than the height of one storey and
you can see it's not just the
neighboring houses actually it's not
just next door on both sides but several
other houses behind
and you can see other houses to the
front have had windows and damage to
their roofs as well metropolitan police
are on the scene
london ambulance service also responding
to the incident but no word yet on any
injuries as a result of that